das ist eine überraschende sensation das
weltraumteleskop jobs hat einen
wasserreichen exoplaneten in etwa 50
lichtjahren entfernung von der erde
aufgespürt vor allem die art und weise
wie dieser planet entdeckt wurde ist
einzigartig und dieser planet wird noch
mehr verraten klicks um science and
future geht es dreimal pro woche
spannende science videos abonniert den
kanal und aktiviert die glocke nur so
verpasst ihr nichts los geht's herzlich
willkommen
das muss man sich im wahrsten sinne des
wortes mal vor augen führen erst anfang
der 90er jahre wurden die ersten
exoplaneten entdeckt bis dahin war es
nur eine vermutung dass auch um andere
sterne als die sonder planeten kreisen
inzwischen haben wir tausende entdeckt
und inzwischen wissen wir auch dass es
sogar erdähnliche planeten darunter gibt
und damit wären wir bei der unendlichen
diskussion gibt es dort außerirdisches
leben oder nicht gibt es überhaupt
außerirdisches leben oder nicht was wir
allerdings wissen es gibt wohl
zahlreiche erdähnliche planeten wo es
genau so aussieht wie bei uns hier und
diese zu finden ist die ganz große
herausforderung und irgendwann mal
wollen wir sie dann so genau beobachten
um herauszufinden ob dort spuren von
zivilisationen zu entdecken sind das
schweizerische astronomie team das im
zentrum der jüngsten entdeckung steht
das hat ja eigentlich etwas ganz anderes
im visier
es ging um das sternsystem nur zwei lupe
bereits vor zwei jahren 2009/10 hatte
man drei exoplaneten aufgespürt die um
einen hellen sonnenähnlichen stern
kreisen
so hatte das forschungsteam vor einiger
zeit die beiden inneren planeten b und c
unter die lupe genommen als es plötzlich
zu der sensationellen entdeckung haben
das planetensystem um den stern nun zwei
lupi befindet sich im sternbild lupus
der lateinische begriff für wolf der
stadt selbst nur 48 lichtjahre von der
erde entfernt und ist sogar mit bloßem
auge zu sehen er leuchtet hell orange
rötlich gelb mit einer masse die etwa
unserer sonne entspricht es handelt sich
um einen sonnenähnlichen
ein stern der vermutlich doppelt so alt
ist wie unser heimat sterben nur zwei
lupe ist somit wahrscheinlich einer der
ältesten sterne in der solaren
nachbarschaft schon in der vergangenheit
hatten sich forschungsteams weltweit für
ihn interessiert vor zwei jahren 2009/10
weil mit hilfe des harps instruments der
europäischen südsternwarte eso in chile
vermessen worden
aus diesen daten wurde klar dass dazu
drei planeten gehören ihre umlaufzeiten
je zwölf tage 28 tage und 108 tagen eine
weitere analyse erfolgte dann mit hilfe
des chips satelliten im vergleich mit
dem nasa-weltraumteleskop tests dass das
weltall nach transit in absucht arbeitet
jobs deutlich präziser einzelsterne von
denen man weiß dass sie exo planeten
beherbergen können mit hilfe des
satelliten ganz genau ins visier
genommen werden während es eben nur
transit also vorbeiziehende planeten
findet und zwar findet es sie weil sich
die sterne das zentralgestirn jeweils
verdunkelt wenn ein planet vorbeizieht
das ist das transit verfahren dieser
analyse also die von jobs' offenbarte
dann dass es sich um die beiden inneren
planeten um sogenannte transitplaneten
handelt nur zwei luki b und 0 2 pc in
der fachsprache ist damit gemeint dass
diese planeten eben regelmäßig vor der
stern scheibe vorbei ziehen und dadurch
die stern strahlung ab dem wichtig
hierbei das ganze ist gemeint aus der
perspektive der erde also sobald sich
ein exoplanet von uns aus gesehen vor
seine sonne schiebt erreicht und
periodisch etwas weniger licht wodurch
fachleute auf seine existenz schließen
können mit hilfe dieser sogenannten
transitmethode werden fast täglich mehr
und mehr exoplaneten aufgespürt laut der
us weltraumagentur nasa sind es
mittlerweile 4400 bestätigte exoplaneten
und rund 7600 mögliche kandidaten für
die forschung sind solche transit
planeten ganz besonders spannende
objekte denn solch ein transit
ermöglicht es den fachleuten die bahn
lage die größe und die atmosphäre des
planeten genauer zu bestimmen durch
diese parameter kann dann letztendlich
auch in das innere der planeten geschaut
werden da diese parameter einiges über
den aufbau der jeweiligen klar
verraten so wollen astronomie teams
langfristig auch endlich verstehen nach
welchen regeln sich planetensysteme
bilden doch selbst es war nicht in der
lage mehr informationen zum dritten
planeten herauszufinden
denn gemessen werden beobachtungs
einheiten von 28 tage zieht dieser
planet also überhaupt vom beobachter von
der erde aus gesehen vor dem stern
vorbei ist seine bahn also überhaupt so
geneigt dass ein so genanntes dran sind
ereignis überhaupt stattfinden kann klar
war es bisher nur dass solch ein transit
des dritten äußeren planeten eigentlich
nicht zu erwarten war
denn die walter hahn planet von einem
stern entfernt ist umso
unwahrscheinlicher wird sein
transitwegen der bahn neigung die die
wahrscheinlichkeit im äußeren bereich
eines planetensystems immer geringer
werden lässt geplant waren dann im
frühjahr des vergangenen jahres 2020
insgesamt sechs beobachtungs den fans
mit jobs das internationale
forschungsteam hatte sich darauf
eingestellt bei dieser analyse
4 dran sitz des planeten b und 3 dran
sitz des planeten zu beobachten zu
können
so wollte man dann langfristig endlich
hinweise auf die beschaffenheit der
planeten bekommt doch dann kam es zu der
spektakulären überraschung eine
planetare foto bombe und damit hatte
wirklich niemand gerechnet das
forschungsteam entdeckt etwas zitat
unglaublich ist auch der dritte ex und
planet nur zwei lob idee tauchte
plötzlich vor dem stern auf dazu sagt
der berner astrophysiker jan albert der
an der aktuellen studie beteiligt waren
was diese exoplaneten wirklich
herausragend machen ist dass wir sie
direkt vor ihrem stern vorbeiziehen
können man spricht von einem dran sind
das wussten wir bereits über die beiden
inneren planeten was uns dazu
veranlasste jobs überhaupt auf das
system zu richtung der dritte planet ist
jedoch ziemlich weit vom stern entfernt
seinen dran sind hatte niemand erwartet
ein total glücklicher zufall also
während des transits ereignisses vom
planet c kam es also zu einem
zusätzlichen abfall der stern
leuchtintensität laut des
forschungsteams mit hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit eben bedingt durch
den transit dritten planeten eine
premiere also denn bislang war es noch
nie gelungen einen exoplaneten mit einer
periode von mehr als 100 tagen zu
sichten der an einem stern vorbeizieht
dem man mit bloßem auge von der erde
aussehen kann
die bislang aufgespürt exoplaneten mit
einer solch langen periode befinden sich
in der nähe von sternen die deutlich
schwächer sind detaillierte beobachtung
sind somit also gar nicht möglich
die astronomische foto bombe war für das
forschungsteam also ein riesiger
glücksfall so kam es also völlig
überraschender weise dazu dass die
vorstände die gelegenheit bekam auch den
orbit die größe atmosphäre und
zusammensetzung des dritten exoplaneten
zu ermitteln die analyse offenbart
spannende details demnach handle sich
bei dem exoplaneten b um einen
gesteinsplaneten planet c und d dagegen
verfügen über gigantische wassermengen
diese sind eingeschlossen in hüllen aus
helium und wasserstoff gas
demnach bestehen diese beiden
exoplaneten sogar aus meerwasser als die
erde so das fazit des forschungsteams
zum vergleich die erde besteht aus
weniger als 0,1 prozent wasser also hier
an der oberfläche ist es natürlich
anders da gibt es viel mehr wasser aber
auf das gesamtvolumen sind es 0 1
prozent wasser und die beiden
exoplaneten dem stern system nur zwei
lupe sogar zu einem viertel
doch das wasser ist wurde nicht für sich
sondern in form von hochdruck eis oder
hochtemperatur dampf vorhanden dazu die
wissenschaftler im cache die an der
studie beteiligt war
keiner der planeten wäre bewohnen war
doch ihre vielfalt macht das system noch
aufregender zumindest für leben wie wir
es bislang kennen bilden diese planeten
wohl kaum eine heimat auch die weiteren
ergebnisse der aktuellen studie sind
spannend der radius des dritten planeten
note 2 luke idee etwa zweieinhalb mal so
groß wie die erde und fast neunmal so
schwer fest steht nur zwei vip de ist
ein ganz besonderer exoplaneten mit
seiner langen bahn periode von 108 tagen
würde in unserem sonnensystem zwischen
merkur und venus liegen da um den sehr
hellen stern nur zwei lippi kreist
handelte sich um ein perfektes
untersuchungsobjekt für die forschung
und für die fachleute ist ja noch aus
einem weiteren grund besonders spannend
denn möglicherweise hat er deutlich mehr
informationen über seine entstehung
gespeichert als anderen bislang
entdeckten exoplaneten dazu schreiben
die wissenschaftlerinnen und
wissenschaftler in unserem sonnensystem
würde nur zwei lupe
die sonne zwischen merkur und venus und
kreisen je weniger strahlung ein planet
erhält desto weniger verändert
er sich im laufe der zeit heißt also
dieser exoplanet bekommt im vergleich zu
anderen eher weniger strahlung seines
sterns ab und deswegen könnte er ganz
besonders interessant für die forschung
seien daher aus diesem grund
möglicherweise mehr informationen über
seine entstehung bewahrt hat große
hoffnung und auf weiteren untersuchungen
die ebenfalls mit hilfe von jobs
erfolgen sollen dazu schreibt das
forschungsteam jobs wird uns nicht nur
dabei helfen bekannten exoplaneten
besser zu verstehen
der satellit wird es uns auch
ermöglichen neue exoplaneten zu
entdecken und ihre geheimnisse zu lüften
aber auch noch deutlich
leistungsfähigere teleskope wie das
james webb weltraumteleskop könnten die
geheimnisse dieser exoplaneten aufdecken
besonders spannend dabei könnte die
zusammensetzung der atmosphäre sein denn
da findet man dann spuren von leben mehr
über die jobs mission gibt es hier
finden wir jetzt aliens chefs mission
nimmt exoplaneten ins visier anklicken
anschauen und abonnieren
das geht hier und unter jedem video mit
dem abo button das kostet nichts und er
verpasst kein video mehr also bis dann
bleibt dran